all right well i'll i'll tell you this
you know we got a lot to complain about
in terms of the destruction of the
economy but uh well
something's happening in europe which is
quite a bit different
germany is going to be placing people
who break quarantine
into detainment camps into either
refugee camps or to
detention centers anybody else get deja
vu from that yeah
germany should be like the one place
that like where there's no camps
nothing not even summer camps
they need to wait until everyone else
decides no no at no point
should we be setting up internment camps
for for things like this when you get to
the point where you're like we're going
to set up a relocation facility like you
got to stop and reflect on what it is
you're doing
all right because what's really fun
about story let me show you the story
this is from the telegraph
germans who keep refusing to quarantine
could be put in detention centers under
new covert rules
in some german states where all other
options have been tried
authorities to detain those who refuse
to enter quarantine
so they mentioned there's a couple
different states like eastern state of
saxony
where hospitals have been struggling to
cope with one of the worst outbreaks
they have confirmed plans to hold
quarantine breakers in a fenced off
section
of a refugee camp what three further
states
baden wardenberg brandenburg and
schleswig holstein i'm not i can't speak
german
have also either already created such
facilities or in the process of doing so
a report in sunday's edition of welt
newspaper stated
in baden-wurttemberg two hospitals will
have rooms reserved for repeat offenders
which will be guarded by police
brandenburg will use a section of a
refugee center
while shall swig holstein will use an
area within a juvenile detention center
well we're at the point now where
they're setting up the camps but uh
i i got i got i got to stop with that
because you know i started this by
saying we got a lot to complain about
but over in europe it's getting bad
well they're proposing this the same
thing in new york state did you hear
about this
yeah and there's actually um there's
there's a whole study
that was put forth on the cdc website
about this and they call them green
zones um yeah you can pull that up
um it basically outlines a plan
to to section off areas of the country
and relocate people who are sick that's
on the cdc website
what the heck that's crazy why would you
put sick people together
and put people there why would you why
would you put people that you think
might be sick all together to make them
more
strict it's like four or five pages it's
it's well thought out they're talking
about
um if if the person who gets sent away
can't care for themselves then somebody
has to go with them so you know if you
have like an elderly parent who's
getting sent away
you're up for the camp as well oh my
gosh what's this called exactly what was
it
this was on the cdc website i think i
may have found it let me see if i'm i
think they refer
to them as green zones i will also point
out on the cdc website it specifically
says there's
no evidence of covet existing in the
food supply
i looked at it up today and but another
thing you have to realize is that the
cdc the world health organization
they keep contradicting themselves
non-stop 24 7. they told us that there
was no
uh human to human transmission no
transmission through
air they flip-flop on the mass they
flipped out on so many things it's very
hard to understand what they're saying
now another thing to really kind of
really consider here and it's kind of
worrisome
especially the news in germany because
they're really pushing this forward but
one of the things that they say is that
this is going to be specifically
for rule breakers what rules are we
talking about these are very generalized
language and when it comes to
the government's response to covid a lot
of the rules are arbitrary
a lot of them are made up a lot of them
have
shown to have no actual effect on
stopping uh
the sickness the lockdowns have been
found in some instances to actually hurt
more people than help people
i i i gotta tell you man for the people
listening just
google search a picture of murphy
governor murphy of new jersey
and i got i can tell you shield your
eyes here's no here's what i think
i'm i'm going to give i'm going to give
you my my my opinion on this okay
you guys got ian smith how tall are you
six foot six foot
and you're you're pretty ripped man you
work out you run a gym once in a while
you've got a sweet spirit
beard and you got the slicked back hair
i think it's personal governor murphy
governor murphy i saw you and you're
like this dude this gym
and he went i want that yeah no no when
when when when the cop sided with you
i bet it was personal i bet he he
thought about himself and being a whiny
loser
and then here's the successful guy he's
running he probably couldn't get it up
that night that's probably what this is
all about
nobody's outside
nerdy guy i really do think he was
personally insulted how dare you
challenge my power
the thing is he's been governor since
january 2018
and he's got massive amounts of power
yeah
way too much for one person yep well
well let's let's
he came in the door like that like like
just
overstepping almost right away let's
let's let's think about this
okay when i when i heard the story of
the cop who came up when you were
mentioning he said you're all in violent
violation of executive order that big
said have a nice day
i'm sure he got so mad like how dare you
i'm the governor you obey me and so he
made that call
threatening to furlough an entire
department unless they've been to his
whim
talk about a lunatic but think about
think about that level of depravity
i pulled up what you talked about this
is really interesting i have cdc.gov
right here and they say
interim operational considerations for
implementing the shielding approach to
prevent covalent 19 infections
in humanitarian settings well hold on
guys shielding
that sounds pretty good right shielding
what does shielding mean they say
uh let's let's see what they say current
evidence indicates that older adults and
people of any age who have serious
underlying medical conditions
are at higher risk for severe severe
illness in most humanitarian settings
older population groups make up a small
percentage of the total population
for this reason the shielding approach
suggests physically separating high-risk
individuals from the general population
to prioritize the use of the limited
available resources
and avoid implementing long-term
containment measures among the general
population
ah let me break that down they're saying
we'll take the people who could get sick
and
we'll remove them from urban areas and
population centers
because we don't want to inconvenience
the general population now hold on
i did say protect the vulnerable allow
the you know
everyone everyone to work i just don't
like the idea of
physically removing people from areas
yeah i'm talking about just like having
a building where it's like a sign on the
door saying at risk for covid
and then having special precautions like
you put the package down they clean it
before bringing it in
not taking the people yeah you can put
like a symbol on their door
yeah that's that's something that hasn't
been tried in nazi germany yeah but
okay so what about armbands if you were
to put notes like that
if you were to put a sign on someone's
store that said this person is at risk
of developing covid please be extra
careful i don't think that's anything
you could put a little star david with a
smiley face next to it
i think it's disgusting i think if
you're going to single people out for a
a invisible uh disease a virus that we
think is out there
and then stuff them in concentration
camps that we're looking at 21st century
genocide we're looking at
world war three and we're declaring it
on ourselves
have you guys seen that movie song bird
you have you heard about it is that the
michael bay one where it's like 2024 and
kovid 23
is like mutated and everyone's locked
down it's an interesting movie because
the government's the bad guy in it and
that but that's the premise of the movie
is that there's these green
zones that your zones cue zones okay so
they they cleverly renamed it from the
cdc website exactly
uh i think that's like the plot of it
right there well check it out so no i
just pulled up the new york state senate
assembly bill a416 now first let me just
say
it's only in committee the bill was
introduced it is in committee
it's not on the floor calendar it has
not passed the senate or the assembly
has not gone to the governor and has not
been signed this might just fizzle out
and die
but this bill basically says and look it
pertains to the removal and detention
of cases contacts and carriers who
are or may be a danger to public health
other orders provisions of the section
shall be utilized in the event if the
governor declares a state of health
emergency
due to an epidemic of any communicable
disease
any but here's my favorite part let's
say it's very broad language it says
it says cases or contacts that may be a
danger
that's what you got to read into what's
a contact that may be a danger
simple let's say you get an amazon
delivery a box on your on your doorstep
you pick it up you open it and there's a
sonic bread knife
yeah and you press the button you cut to
the bread we're getting one of those by
the
way
so let's let's see what you get you get
one of those carving knives you know
then someone shows up your door and it's
a little cuomo and he's like
you were in contact with a box
from someone who is sick therefore
you may be a danger and they'll detain
you what about the mailman
mail gets coveted everyone on the mail
route now well the thing you got to
understand here is that
the language here is very generalized
and there's going to be yeah it's done
like that many times because the
government could then look at this
little piece of paper and say well we
could interpret this
any which way we want and probably
because of
some privacy or hipaa laws you won't
even know if it's the mailman or if it's
somebody else
it'll be kept away from you and and the
thing that's really kind of scary here
actually is is that everything about
covid has been almost
political whether it's the alcohol
stores the gambling the walmart's costco
blm protest
the the lockdowns the selective uh
you know politicking of this entire
scenario we have seen it
bastardized and used and abused for
political power to the highest extent
what makes you think that this higher
authority that this government is
demanding from you
that it won't corrupt them to use it and
abuse it against
other political enemies i figured it out
ian why don't you just
while everyone's working out chant hey
hey ho ho
racism has got to go what if a black
lives matter banner
they won't touch it we thought about
that we thought
we thought about just smashing our own
windows in and
you would just run in and pick up some
dumbbells and then run out with them
that'd be great that was that was your
workout you were just moving things
no but i mean like what would happen if
you actually just
invited some activists down i mean
here's the interesting thing look they
don't like cops
right and the cops the ones shutting you
down what if you just said hey black
lives matter do you want to have an
event here
they uh black lives matter got very
upset with me because
um the the local black lives matter in
in the philadelphia south jersey area
contacted me and told me that
i needed to put a black square on my
profile um
because yeah um i was contacted by
more than one person saying you need to
do this because you have a voice
and we supported you opening um and i
said and that was
during the whole george floyd thing and
i said i don't know enough about this
situation to do that
and and i'm going to use my platform
because that was when my platform
started growing you know yeah once we
reopened i went on tucker carlson
i started to grow you know on social
media and then it was expected of me
to do that i hate it when people do they
if i invited them i don't think they
would come on
no you know what i mean i mean i can't
blame you because if someone comes to me
and says do this
you know you have to yeah i'm not going
to even if they're like if someone does
something for you and then they
expect something of you it's so
obnoxious right but you know what i
would say
i like it the saying is there's no no
there is there is no
no in business if someone comes to me
says i want you to do this i say okay
here are my terms
so if if someone came to me and said you
know black lives matter we want your
profile to be you know
black square i'd be like sounds good to
me will you guys show up we'll make a
big thing of it like
you'll come down to my my gym will open
up you guys will protest
and then i'll pull out my phone and i'll
do it and we'll high five how does that
sound
but what are the cops the capital then
then your gym's open you know what i
mean and then
you know i returned okay you got it you
know what i mean come down you support
us
protest the cops but i guess especially
the time you guys are trying to be
respectful
to the police yeah i'm sorry i had the
fight with the governor to attend to i
didn't i didn't really have time for
you know being being everybody's
advocate i was trying to be an advocate
for small business
yeah uh and and myself and my family and
that was that was apparently
unacceptable
i'm you know uh i don't know if you've
seen the uh the boogaloo boy stuff
like the boogaloo boys they're out and
they're with
black lives matter like there's black
lives matter person standing next to a
guy with a hawaiian shirt on or whatever
which is a change of tone
for the the boogaloo boys i don't think
so i don't know no not the boo
so there's there's a video from months
ago where
the boogaloo boys wearing their hawaiian
shirts and tactical vests and guns are
marching around with black lives matter
and then antifa this is this is crazy
video an anti-foot there's an antivo on
the left
boogaloo boys on the right and the end
of a guy shakes the hand of the boogaloo
boy and says
i know we don't agree but you stood with
you stood with us today and for that we
respect you
and the boogaloo boy says we agree with
you man we we agree with you completely
we just we all we don't like the
government so i think that's where we
can start
and they're together like which makes no
sense though because
i mean blm and and antifa
go running to the left and they you know
they they eat out of the hands of kamala
harris and
and the politicians on the left who who
pander to them
and the boogaloo boys do not go to the
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you